the hunger games mockingjay part dos
this is the final movie in The Hunger
Games franchise where Katniss Everdeen
must work with other rebels to take down
President Snow who blows that's been the
plot for quite some time it's about time
it comes to a finale I'll start off by
saying the acting in this is as solid as
ever Jennifer Lawrence is a fantastic
job once again the plane Katniss
Everdeen as a woman who's on the brink
of just losing it you know she's sick
and tired of this war although we expect
that from Jennifer Lawrence we expect
you to be good Jennifer Lawrence the one
that really impressed me was Josh
Hutcherson as Peeta now I've never had
issues with his performance but I've
always thought the character it could be
more compelling to watch this movie
Peeta is traumatized from the events
that happened with snow when he was
kidnapped and he's been brainwashed into
believing Katniss is the real enemy and
he like really believes that the
dynamics of forms between Katniss and
Peeta is actually the most interesting
part of this movie before we saw Peeta
as like one of katniss's loyal boys to
see his major distrust towards her made
for some really compelling drama
especially when Katniss is just really
hoping that Peeta will go back to who he
once was and I enjoyed this movie
however the film is not flawless a lot
of my issues come with the drama of this
movie I felt like a lot of things were
on repeat I mean there's only so many
scenes in a franchise that I could watch
people telling Katniss how special she
is crowds for me when Katniss shows up
Katniss giving some repetitive
rebellious speech kindness seen how snow
has to die and Katniss deciding between
Peeta and Gale yeah we will see the ls
stuff before and some scenes that
feature different drama I felt dragged
on for too long there was some off pace
the film sometimes move slower than I
felt it should have which is weird to
say cuz totally justifiable why it moves
slowly I mean this is a gloomy dark
world like when they answer the capital
it's practically a ghost town so it kind
of moves slow kind of like a Western min
away not that I thought they were going
for a Western vibe but that's what I
thought so the slow-moving tension
decision makes sense but sometimes the
film just had some really boring scenes
however the adventure is quite thrilling
a lot of the time because the adventure
really takes place from Canada sand
team decide to invade the capital and
it's practically abandoned the capital
turns into the new Hunger Games in a way
there's pod set up to annihilate any
human being that hits this like
mousetrap peacekeepers are ready at a
moment's notice to attack I mean there's
some truly intense sequences on this
adventure can't give anything away but
the teases we got on the trailer like of
that black tarp thingy liquid better no
attacking them those zombie-like
creatures the intensity of this team
being on their own where they have to
take on the whole capital feature some
truly intense moments and some wonderful
action I mean overall I felt like the
film had a decent balance of cutting
back to draw my and going back to action
even though I felt that times the drama
was like new mission same old drama I
can't spoil anything but a lot of people
are killed off in this film a lot of
people are killed off however so many
deaths seem to be occurring that they
quickly lose their emotional impact
there's one death of a main supporting
character that I felt like really should
have had an impact on Katniss I mean yes
we get it in several scenes later where
we're like okay so she is bothered by
this death but still when the death took
place have felt rushed and I felt like
they used the character as a plot device
like it was very apparent that they're
setting up this character to die in the
movie I do want to point out though that
I thought Donald Sutherland us know I
felt he was more compelling to watch
this time around he's usually rather one
note throughout these movies but I felt
like we got a good sense of loss and
despair and loneliness that we didn't
really get from President Snow before
and I even found Gale to be more
interesting in this film usually I kind
of don't care about Gail that I felt his
personality more in this film I felt his
purpose and he has this great scene
where him and Peeta are having a
conversation one-on-one that i thought
was one of my favorite moments of the
film now even though i'm pointing out
that a lot of the drama was repetitive
and that a lot of deaths were not really
felt i don't want people to think like I
didn't like it at all or even most of
the drama because like I've been saying
there are some truly powerful moments
for these characters it's just that this
is a final film in a franchise that had
to tie up a lot of loose ends same time
keep honoring the source material so
like with the final major twist of this
film I mean I thought it was inch
it even features a great scene between
Katniss and snow but even then I felt
that to us could have been more
impactful if I was more invested in the
character that the twist took place
around and I felt like a lot of
characters don't really get resolution
or a payoff by the end of this movie now
this isn't a spoiler because there's
nothing to spoil but hey Mitch for
example the way they wrapped up his
character was a letdown to me they
didn't wrap up his character you see
that from the first Hunger Games damage
is this traumatized disturbed angry
alcoholic good because of the past
events that he had to survive yet by the
end of the film i got i felt like we got
no real closure on the guy and I heard
they honored the book when it came to
this moment but we spend four movies
going is Katniss gonna choose pita or
gale and in the end with who she chooses
I felt like she didn't even make the
choice I would have liked to have seen
her go you know what I'm going with this
guy rather than something happening
where you're like whoa okay well that
guy's kind of a dick now so of course
she's gonna go with this other guy I
just only cop-outs like that we're the
love interest has to choose between two
characters and so just making a decision
they make one of them out to look bad so
that way they're like okay Candace will
obviously choose the other one I really
respected the way this movie ended this
film doesn't end in a way like all is
happy now I mean if anything that trauma
and horror is still really resonating in
these characters you really see that in
war there is no real winners and it's
not all beautiful by the end so I
respected that this film did feel like
this story has concluded but it
concludes in a rather dark way I hear
the books even significantly darker I
was still satisfied with going like yeah
this is not the ending I expected but I
like it last thing I want to say
Mockingjay did not need to be split into
two movies this was the final film in a
huge franchise I think audiences would
have stuck around for three-plus hours
for one epic film so yeah some of the
drama is repetitive a lot of the deaths
were not really felt I felt like a lot
of characters needed some resolution but
in the end the action was great the
performances were fantastic there's some
great drama between the character
interactions specifically because of the
acting and I feel like an Indian
there is enough conclusions that will
bring some type of resolution or closure
for the audience and it's much better
than Mockingjay part 1 hated that film
anyway guys that's it for my review of
the Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2
apparently people can't tell how I feel
about a film and let's say you have a
rating I give you three and a half
testicles out of a scrub yep anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it subscribe today and
become a reject because I'm a youtuber
naming the fan base that's so cool
nothing like a cheap gimmick to hook
people and you just gave away the
secrets of youtubers